rheumatoid arthritis is a common
autoimmune disorder of the joints that
affects about 1% of the population
worldwide more often women than men the
exact causes of the disease are unknown
but an individual's risk is thought to
be increased by a combination of genetic
and environmental factors many of the
genes associated with rheumatoid
arthritis are involved in immune system
function non genetic risk factors
include age diet infectious agents and
smoking in an autoimmune disorder such
as rheumatoid arthritis the immune
system mistakenly attacks and destroys
the body's own cells and tissues which
immunologists refer to as self and this
autoimmunity can begin many years before
joint symptoms are noticed doctors can
use blood tests to identify this
preclinical phase by the presence of
multiple factors in the blood such as
Auto antibodies and inflammatory factors
these early auto antibodies are thought
to first develop outside of the joints
possibly in the gut mouth or lungs
environmental factors such as smoking
can modify our self proteins making them
targets for the immune system one
particular modification is called citral
ination
when the immune system recognizes these
modified self proteins it leads to a
breach of self tolerance and the
production of autoreactive b-cells and
auto antibodies and later or two
reactive t-cells the hallmarks of
autoimmune disease by the time that
symptoms appear the immune response has
intensified and the antibodies produced
target abroad a range of self proteins
but it's only in some patients that this
systemic autoimmunity progresses to
joint inflammation which is possibly
triggered by an increase in joint
permeability and increased access to
antibodies
looking out how to prevent this
progression is a major goal for
scientists in patients who do develop
joint disease the small joints of the
hands and feet are most commonly
affected after entering a joint immune
cells and Auto antibodies bind to
modified self proteins in the cartilage
bone and lining of the joint of the
synovium this induces an inflammatory
response and activate cells in the joint
such as macrophages neutrophils and
osteoclasts as well as blood monocytes
activated monocytes differentiate into
yet more macrophages which together with
other cells in the joint produce soluble
inflammatory factors known as cytokines
drugs targeting these cytokines are
highly effective treatments for many
patients left unchecked however damage
caused by the inflammatory environment
can expose new self antigens to the
immune system continuing the cycle at
this stage the first clinical symptoms
of joint pain swelling and warmth appear
some patients recover but most commonly
patients develop a chronic destructive
disorder as the disease progresses
dendritic cells display the newly
exposed self antigens and activate
t-cells in the joint itself or in the
local lymph node in addition b-cells
infiltrate the joint where they
proliferate and produce antibodies and
other factors further amplifying the
autoimmune response cells in the joint
lining called fibroblasts like synovial
sites also proliferate and grow into the
joint space spreading across to the
cartilage surface
these cells secrete matrix degrading
enzymes which erode the cartilage tissue
bone is also eroded as osteoclasts which
contribute to normal bone turnover
become hyperactive a t-bone erosion
cartilage destruction and joint swelling
caused severe pain restrict movement of
the joint and in the worst cases can
cause joint deformities and as well as
the joints other organs and body systems
can be affected by the ongoing
information for example information in
the blood vessels can lead to heart
disease so early and aggressive therapy
is recommended to prevent these systemic
complications by further understanding
the immune markers and mechanisms of
rheumatoid arthritis it's hoped that
targeted interventions could ultimately
change the course of the disease